[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to a very special christmas
themed installment
of harry potter theory in honor of the
holidays
i'm going to be covering some aspects of
christmas and how they pertain to
hogwarts
students and the magical world as a
whole if you're anything like me
and you grew up with harry potter then
harry potter and christmas
go hand in hand whether it's the
carriages taking the students to
hogwarts in the snow
the weasley family gifting ugly jumpers
or the hogwarts banquet hall completely
decked out with christmas decorations
and lights
i can guarantee one thing it's going to
feel christmassy
hogwarts is already such a magical place
but covered in snow
it almost seems even more magical
christmas was coming
one morning in mid-december hogwarts
woke to find itself covered in several
feet of snow
the lake froze solid and the weasley
twins were punished for bewitching
several snowballs
so that they followed quirrell around
bouncing off the back of his turban
the few owls that managed to battle
their way through the stormy sky to
deliver mail
had to be nursed back to health by
hagrid before they could fly off again
but despite the beautiful scenery at the
school students do actually get a chance
to head home for the holidays
so that they can be reunited with their
families in some instances
however students actually have the
option of staying at hogwarts for the
duration of the school break
we see this with harry potter in the
first film as his only other option
would be to return to the home of the
dursleys during the second week of
december
professor minerva mcgonagall would make
a list of all of the students who
decided to stay
at the school so that they wouldn't feel
left out presents were always piled at
the foot of these students beds
so they could find them upon waking on
christmas morning
lovely in fact harry's first year at
hogwarts was the first year in his life
that he had received proper presence
will you look at this
i've got some presents what did you
expect turnips
i can't even begin to imagine the
christmas scene at the dursley residence
with uncle vernon stuffing his face
deadly complaining about the number of
presents he's received and petunia
trying desperately to calm
her sweet young boy in fact if you stay
at hogwarts
you don't miss out on any aspect of
christmas they even put on a feast
harry had never in all his life had such
a christmas dinner
a hundred fat roast turkeys mountains of
roast and boiled potatoes
platters of chipolatas terrines of
buttered peas
silver boats of thick rich gravy and
cranberry sauce
and stacks of wizard crackers every few
feet along the table
harry pulled a wizard cracker with fred
and it didn't just bang
it went off with a blast like a cannon
and engulfed them in a cloud of blue
smoke while from the inside exploded
a rear admiral's hat and several live
white mice
given that harry almost never returned
home to the dursleys for christmas
he had very fond memories of his time at
hogwarts over the december months
and though he later spent his christmas
nights at either the borough or grimmeld
place
his first couple at hogwarts really
touched him when visiting godric hollow
in 1997
he was reminded of these times when
carols echoed from a nearby church
peeves bellowing rude versions of carols
from inside suits of armor of the great
hall's twelve christmas trees
of dumbledore wearing a bonnets he'd won
in a cracker of ron in a hand-knitted
sweater
i know one thing for sure i'm going to
have the first film on repeat this
christmas
am i the only one that thinks harry
potter and christmas go hand in hand
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
one can never have enough socks said
dumbledore another christmas has come
and gone and i didn't get a single pair
people will insist on giving me books